hello and welcome to Intelligence
Squared with me and mikelvoy I'm very
excited to introduce our guest and our
subject today the subject is Shopify and
Entrepreneurship in the digital age
which appeals to me because I'm
fascinated by Tech Innovation and I also
shop a lot
and fittingly our guest is Harley
Finkelstein business person entrepreneur
public speaker best known as president
of Shopify which is the multinational
Commerce platform allowing entrepreneurs
to start up run and grow business hi
there Harley
hey Ann great to be here and thank you
for that lovely introduction uh very
cool to hear that the Venn diagram
overlap of of technology and and
shopping uh is coming together for this
particular episode you definitely got
the right host on this one I can assure
you and I'm just going to start perhaps
by getting our terms out there a bit I
mean Shopify sounds like it it does what
the name suggests but it is really a
place of many levels and many functions
and it's also a kind of business in its
own right which is acting as a
subscription service am I broadly right
you are broadly right
um really the the mission of Shopify is
is to increase the amount of
entrepreneurs on the planet and we do so
by making it really easy to get started
um you know someone sitting at their
mom's kitchen table can start a business
on Shopify for 29 or uh you know
something like that and then over time
as that business gets really big becomes
you know gymshark or all birds or you
know fiori or you know figs or frankly
even some of the large cpgs like Procter
Gamble can also continue to sell on
Shopify I think the thing that most
people get wrong about Shopify is
because we are so well known to be an
e-commerce provider most people assume
that we are you know we make it easy to
sell online only and actually
our view is that the future retail is
retail everywhere and we'll get into
that later on in in our conversation but
we make it really easy to sell in store
in person we make it real easy to sell
on places like Instagram and Tick Tock
and snap and and Pinterest and and
everywhere in between
um and then the other part that I think
people get wrong about Shopify is that
if you were to pretend the Shopify was a
single retailer we're not a retailer we
have millions of stores that you Shopify
but if you were to aggregate all those
stores we would be the second largest
online retailer in America and so the
reason I mentioned that is because part
of what we've been doing the last few
years is going ahead and finding all the
other friction points or problem areas
in building a real great Commerce or
retail business like shipping and
fulfillment and payments and capital
um and international selling and making
really easy to sort of you know
leveraging these economies of scale to
level the playing field so that if you
are starting a business today at your
mom's kitchen table anywhere in the
world the payment rates you were getting
the shipping rates that you were getting
your ability to access capital is
effectively the same as someone who is
working a very large company and that
leveling of the playing field is really
our mission yeah it's funny I was just
about to say it is kind of flattening
off what used to be in a hierarchy
depending on you know how much your
backers would would back you or indeed
how successful you were already and the
fact that you're supporting so many
breakthrough businesses seems to me
particularly important and exciting
let's look to Black Friday huge of
course in North America and has crossed
the pond as an idea and a good way to
prod us to say to spend rather than say
for the holidays but it is a very
difficult time in terms of economic
backdrop in most places how important is
this Black Friday specifically to you
it is really important uh it's important
to us it's also important to the
millions of stores that use Shopify I
mean it is it is the biggest Commerce
moment of the year and part of that is
you know Merchants desire to sell and
and also the consumer's interest in
purchasing products
um often at a discounted price and and
so you know Black Friday Cyber Monday or
you know bfcm as the industry calls it
has grown over the years to be you know
not just a weekend a four day weekend
from Friday to Monday but but actually
more of a shopping season and more and
more what you're seeing is it's starting
even earlier uh starting in early
November we see it the highest
participation from Merchant consumers
over the Black Friday Cyber Monday
weekend kind of starts like you know the
first of of November or the end of end
of uh October
but it really is a very crucial sales
period for entrepreneurs and businesses
um 73 this is a really interesting stat
73 of businesses worldwide say that
they're planning for a pretty big black
Friday Cyber Monday and in the U.S and
Spain it actually Rises to about 80 and
79 respectively so I think you know the
key here is that all year round
um but in particular during these these
Key Shopping season our top motivator is
to help merchants and um we've been at
this for about 16 years or so
um and I think this year in particular
is one of the most important ones
specifically because this is really the
first Black Friday and Cyber Monday kind
of post pandemic and I think a lot has
changed in terms of how we look at
Commerce and how we look at retail today
well that's exactly exactly where my
mind was going without I think the sort
of nervousness that we had last year
certainly the year before when we were
fully into pandemic mode about going
shopping at all and the sensors or
pulling back a bit from life that is not
there certainly and not in in so many
places but has it affected consumer
Behavior compared to the years when
social distancing was at the Forefront
of people's thinking maybe they weren't
going out so much is there a return to a
sort of you know yippity do let me go
out and purchase or indeed purchase
online or how do we learn habits of
caution that are maybe not so good for
retailers or for people whose platforms
support them
yeah I mean if you think about sort of
the main
um equation or metric that most people
really consider when they talk about
sort of the future of Commerce or future
retail is the e-commerce penetration
rate which is a very simple equation
right in the numerator it is e-commerce
sales and in the denominator it's total
retail sales
and during the pandemic kind of two
things happen
um the the numerator went up obviously
e-commerce went up dramatically and then
obviously the denominator at the bottom
went down because you kind of remove
physical retail so now that physical
retail is reopening and we'll talk about
this because it's getting really
interesting right now what's happening
in physical retail which is by far it is
it is not dead at all in fact there's
absolutely a re-emergence of in-person
shopping which uh a lot of it we're
powering ourselves
um but it looked like during the
pandemic you saw this massive increase
in e-commerce penetration and today now
that reach physical retail is reopening
there's sort of this concern that well
what has happened in e-commerce well
what's really interesting is that
e-commerce has reset on a much higher
base so you know my grandparents for
example who are in their uh 89 years old
my grandmother my grandfather's 91. even
though you know I've been the leader of
Shopify for a long time they never
bought online the pandemic happened and
they discover things like instacart and
ubereats and they discovered online
shopping for the first time because they
had no choice well now that stores have
reopened here in Canada and all over the
world they're still using instacart
they're still using doordash and they're
still buying stuff online so the
e-commerce growth rate in the two years
of the pandemic have obviously exploded
and now they're kind of going back to
2019 growth rates but on a much much
higher base
now to answer your question directly
because it's an important question in
terms of how did you know what happened
in terms of consumer spending and what
do we think consider spending is going
like what is happening now given that
we're kind of in this really tough place
from an economy macroeconomy perspective
so here's what we are seeing certainly
consumer spending is is more considered
but there are a couple things that we
are seeing from consumers in fact to
understand this much better we we just
conducted a global study of more than 24
000 consumers and 9 000 smbs in 12
markets in Europe and and and and North
America
um and in an aipac and the findings show
that there is a shift away from
um you know stack them high sell them
cheap towards more of this high quality
durable products and I think it actually
highlights the importance of businesses
connecting directly with consumers
across all service all services so for
example
um more than uh more than three and four
but 76 percent of Shoppers globally are
looking to spend money on quality
products that are durable
um now that's a shift you know there's
about 46 percent of consumers would
switch to a rival brand for a superior
product
clarify it too on that like it just
sounds a bit like before they didn't did
Shoppers ever really say well I'm not
really after quality product are you
suggesting that it's kind of fast
cycling is changing I think one of the
things that has shifted around sort of
this Black Friday Cyber Monday selling
season is it was all about sort of
Steals and Deals it was all about
getting the greatest discount possible
and now what's happening is people still
want a discount but they're looking for
a bit of an Arbitrage opportunity
they're looking for a great product that
a month ago they wanted but was too
expensive but now might actually be at
the right price point for them and I
think um you know there's no doubt about
if you look at younger Generations
bargain hunting to get value for money
um frankly before the bills bite is
really important 57 percent of consumers
plan to spend the same amount as last
year's Black Friday Cyber Monday or even
more before they feel the pinch of what
they say are our price hikes that are
coming and this is very cute for Gen Z
but I think that the one thing that is
is now no longer a fad but almost steady
state is that both businesses and
consumers tell us that they will not
budge on sustainability despite while
like the wallet squeeze in fact you know
this idea there was a term a couple
years ago called conscious consumerism
and you saw a lot of these you know shoe
companies you buy one shoe they gave
away another shoe or a sunglass company
you buy a pair of sunglasses they gave
it they gave away one for free to
someone in need that was sort of looked
at as almost like a marketing tactic
whereas what we've noticed is that's not
a marketing tactic conscious consumerism
is really this steady state way of
buying now in fact one one thing that I
I've been feeling even in my own buying
behavior is
when I buy a product from a brand it
sort of now feels like it is my way of
voting with my wallet to support that
brand that product that way of doing
business and I think that is more
pronounced now than ever before
one Trend in recent years has been the
Creator economy as something as I
suppose not just for super motivated
people like yourself Who start
businesses or who do things at the the
kitchen table which then end up with a
much bigger kitchen table or indeed
kitchen tables all over the world but
influences if you like who are part of
the product themselves they're on
YouTube they're on Instagram and they're
monetizing Their audience online how do
you see this new Creator economy fitting
with the wide or even the traditional
world of Commerce and all the the rules
that I suppose we thought governed it
and I might have said well I can
probably draw you a graph or certainly
one of my uh my colleagues could that
said well this is what's likely to
happen in a recession is that graph now
more variable because of this trend
yeah well there's a couple things that
have sort of happened the last couple
years
um if you go back to
I don't know go back 50 years go back 30
years 20 years ago people that had
influence
you know celebrities actors musicians
they were often connected to a product
in a very promotional way so you know
this is like
um you know Brad Pitt being um being in
an ad for a watch company or it would be
you know Mick Jagger being uh you know
being an ad for I don't know uh some
some product Apple for example an Apple
product there was a connection to the
product but it always kind of felt like
a promotion always felt like sponsorship
what started to happen and by the way
probably the best example of of that is
in 1982 Michael Jordan creating the
Jordan brand with Nike he kind of
changed everything because all of a
sudden now it wasn't a promotional
product you know you know arguably one
of the best sneakers to play basketball
was the Jordan sneaker so it didn't feel
like he was just slopping his logo on a
pair of generic sneakers it felt like he
was involved in the r d process it felt
like he was involved with the brand
but Michael Jordan did not own the
Jordan brand he was paid a royalty Nike
actually owned the brand and that was
sort of the way it kind of you know it
kind of happened
in the last couple years you began to
see
um you know the the canonical example I
guess this point is is people like Kylie
Jenner creating Kylie Cosmetics or Kim
Kardashian creating skims uh her
shapewear line which actually are not
promotional products which in the
category of Cosmetics or shapewear in
both those categories they are the
leading product in some in some you know
for some demographics in some in in some
areas
um and they own the brand themself now
why were they able to do so because
fundamentally they didn't they they had
an idea they had access to manufacturing
but they also had distribution they also
had the ability to access all of these
consumers and fans through social media
and their own uh their own channels so
so that sort of created this this
interesting New Philosophy a new um new
New Concept whereby you have a collision
between people that create content uh
and create media but also Commerce and
and this sort of collision of Commerce
and and creators has sort of led to this
Creator economy which I think is really
fascinating so ultimately what I think
what what I think we're seeing here is
that
brands of all kinds are now a lot more
comfortable partnering in a much deeper
way with these sort of influencers and
with people online in fact one of the
things that I think is from a consumer
perspective is important is if there is
an influencer or there is a creator that
you watch on YouTube or that you're
really excited by because you know you
read their blog posts and maybe they're
a reporter or a uh they're someone who
who covers a particular topic for you
them endorsing a product especially a
product that they are deeply involved
with will create a much higher
conversion rate because I trust this
person I read Anne's columns and I read
what Ann is writing and if Anne believes
that this is the best you know Coffee
Company
I like her I've been reading her stuff
for years I'm gonna go and buy that
coffee and I realize I've missed a
massive niche in the market
you were absolutely an influencer here
but then you also have these Mega
creators these Mega influencers like Mr
Beast who's this incredible phenomenal
phenomenon and someone who has this sort
of Genius of understanding
um how to build an audience how to
provide value for his audience and and
he's been on Shopify since he had like
three million subscribers on YouTube now
he has a hundred million subscribers and
so now when he creates feastables uh by
by Mr Beast which is a chocolate bar
company or he creates the Mr Beast
Burger chain which has hundreds of
locations all over the United States
he actually is able to build a business
at a trajectory and a velocity that has
never been seen ever before in in
frankly like in the history of business
creation and can I just like put it
through in a challenge here because that
is extraordinary in those numbers I mean
uh you know there's certainly sort of
making my eyes pop but Brands and as far
as I understand you obvious saying that
they are more comfortable partnering
with influencers in this way right
they're not just trying to get out of
George Clooney to sell more Nespresso
toothpicks or something right yeah but
at the same time it does seem to me that
it weakens the identity of Brands
because the brand in a way is and I
think you've described it very very well
and with lots of great examples that
sort of become the influencer they
become the person on YouTube they become
in some way the followers
and doesn't that have big downside risks
for what we thought of as a brand which
has a durability which may sometimes Wax
and Wane and may have better fortunes
one year than a next but has a
consistency to it if it's well managed
continues to grow
I mean that's the Michael Jordan example
I think right which is you know we're
now 38 39 years later from when the
Jordan brand was created Michael Jordan
does not play basketball anymore but
that brand has durability has longevity
to it I'll give you another example that
I think is is also important because
it's sort of I think it addresses one of
the concerns or problems that you uh you
describe which is okay well if you're
Nike it's easy for you to go sign a big
contract with Michael Jordan but what if
you're not Nike
um
two weeks ago uh uh gymshark which is uh
an incredible brand Global brand started
in the UK by by Ben Francis
um he opened up his first physical store
a flagship store on Regent Street and
again we'll get into physical retail in
just a moment but the way that Jim shark
was able to really get to this the scale
that they are today a multi-billion
dollar uh you know brand that frankly is
challenging likes of Nike and and
Lululemon and pretty much every athletic
company on the planet is early on what
Ben did was he didn't have a lot of
money for marketing but he was able to
identify
what he would call Micro influencers
people on on social media but just
frankly like personal trainers in London
in the UK in the UK area who had a small
client base and he would say look
you have 20 or 30 clients uh or you have
200 followers or 2000 followers I'm
going to send you some gym shark apparel
some gymshark clothing and I'll send it
to you for free and all I ask is that if
you like it talk about it and if you
don't like it let me know you don't like
it and give me some feedback
that is a great example of how using
um those micro influencers that those
those communities
um you were able to build a brand with
not a lot of money and I think Ben would
sort of agree that Jim shark would not
be this iconic Global brand many years
later if it wasn't for the leverage of
those small micro influencers as well
now your your your previous point is a
good one which is like okay so Kylie has
Kylie cosmetics and it's a great brand
and I mean if you if you know the story
of of that Cosmetic Company she really
cares about the r d she cares about the
design like the product is is is
something that is her life's work but if
if there's a scandal that happens at
some point does that also affect the
company interesting and I think I think
it does but I don't think it does more
so than
you finding out that your favorite you
know underwear company or sock company
uh you know is is is is using practices
in their Factory which you don't believe
are ethical practices I think the same
thing exists across any every brand it's
just as opposed to talking about a
company you're talking about an
individual
so if you take the example that you gave
us just before we we felt to talking
about that kind of brand risk which is
Mr Beast which is just such
extraordinary you might just remind me
again of the the that Top Line number
100 million subscribers that's not 100
million views that means every time he
puts out a video it is delivered to 100
million people directly and and it is
pushed to them I mean that's an
unbelievable number I mean the Super
Bowl doesn't see those type of numbers
well I was going to say that it just
sounds like numbers that are so off the
charts I'm taking it on trust that
you're right about that one but what
steps would you say he's taking to
become such a successful content creator
creative entrepreneur I do understand
that some things are you know better
thought through than others jump shark
hit it's like guys still just basically
the it's the right Kool-Aid but that is
as you say that's such a kind of sort of
breaks the numbers kind of example can
you just tell us what's been so special
about it
it's it's value creation um if you if
you watch any of his videos that he does
uh we actually did a video with him last
last week where we sort of created our
own version of dragon Center shark tank
with him where you sent him a pitch uh I
think a 30 second Pitch about your
business on Tick Tock he would review
pitches and he would start giving out
ten thousand dollars to the pitches that
he thought were the best pitches
um he's not asking for Equity he didn't
ask for any type of promotion for
himself he just he is someone that very
much pays It Forward consistently about
those things and yes he definitely you
know when squid game first came out it
was this sort of you know cultural hit
in the Zeitgeist of of the world he
created his own version of a squid game
uh didn't didn't harm anyone and gave
away money instead all of his videos are
there not just to entertain but also to
fundamentally
um give out uh you know paid forward and
he talks about some of these videos will
cost him a few million dollars and he's
okay with that because ultimately
he's playing a much longer game than any
type of you know Commercial Business
content creation machine which is always
looking for an Roi he is looking for
indirect Roi over over a long period of
time and I think that's the reason why
he's become the largest content creator
on the planet there's also this other
aspect to this whole idea where you know
the we as consumers we as viewers of
this content we want things that are
compelling we're sort of you know it's
the reason why um I think YouTube has
become one of the greatest platforms for
for distribution of great content
because we as consumers we want things
that are interesting but like we all
have a bit of a niche we talked about
the Venn diagram for example if I'm
really into coffee and I'm really into
you know uh like a sort of the geeky
side and nerdy side of coffee creation
roasting of the beans pour over
methodology there's probably thousands
of videos that I can watch on YouTube
that really is interesting just to me it
may not be interesting to you but that's
the cool part of this sort of the
internet in general is that everyone can
find their own Niche there and I think
what what a lot of the ones that have
been successful have done is they've
really honed their content for their
particular Niche really really well
so let's look to that back up of
slobalization high inflation slow
economic growth across a lot of the the
main economies and of course the the
disruptions and back portion of
geopolitics in there too particularly
the war in Ukraine how important do you
think that is to the future of
Entrepreneurship what does it change for
people who may be thinking well I'm good
to set up my business it might start
very small it might end up you know
being better big or nearly as big
perhaps as as Mr Beast but I'm going to
have a go do you think that that is
likely to be something that takes a bit
of a knock
I mean during the pandemic we saw
um if you just look at U.S the U.S
Census Bureau data
um
2021 saw the highest amount of business
registrations
since I think 2004 there were 5.3
business new businesses created business
registrations in in 2021 in the us alone
so a couple of things I think around
entrepreneurship there is this
connotation in entrepreneurship is still
out of touch for most people it's either
too expensive or it's too complicated
but the interesting part about it is
like a lot of people have hobbies but
yet they don't have necessarily small
businesses and that's not to say that
everyone that has a hobby should
commercialize their hobby but there are
a lot of people that have jobs that they
just don't really love
um they work at places that don't really
you know give them great joy that don't
necessarily give them a great meaning
but they do so because they have no
choice
what I think is so fascinating with
entrepreneurship is that I think it's
been the best way to self-actualize for
a very long time in entrepreneurship is
as old as as you know as the founding of
of currency however the main ingredient
to starting a business has historically
always been the same thing it was
Capital do you have money to start a
business with and um my family are
immigrants to Canada my my grandfather
uh with my father and a few others came
and siblings came over to Canada in 1956
from Hungary after the Holocaust and the
Hungarian Revolution and they sort of
became entrepreneurs by necessity they
didn't really like he was an egg he was
an egg uh he had an egg stall at a
farmer's market my grandfather he didn't
really necessarily love eggs per se but
entrepreneurship was his way to put a
roof over their heads and put food on
the table
if the egg business would not have
succeeded they would have lost
everything and I think that type of
risk or that type of uncertainty about
entrepreneurship that it's sort of if
you if it doesn't work we lose
everything has created
um this sense of Entrepreneurship is
scary and and not for everyone but one
of the cool Parts about my role at shop
of being in prison shop by the last you
know decade and a half or so is that I
have watched random people with no
business experience turn their small
hobby into a business and that business
grow to be a million dollar a billion
dollar business that's the Albert story
The Fig story the gymshark story and I
think one of the things that has made it
much easier
um is technology this idea that you can
set up a store right now at your mom's
kitchen table or at a coffee shop and
you can within a matter of an hour be
selling to a global audience that really
really matters and that was not possible
even even 20 years ago
um and so I think this idea of the law
of Entrepreneurship being more
accessible being less expensive whereas
if you don't if you start I mean it
failed you can try three other things
and not necessarily have to go and go
into debt over it that I think is a
really really good thing but our our
well that's what we're trying to do we
want to create more surface area so more
people that have ideas in the shower can
take that idea and after they got out of
the shower go ahead and try their heads
generally depends on the product but I
do think a lot of people perhaps young
people are entrepreneurs almost without
knowing it and one thing that's happened
with the flattening of platforms and
Shopify is I think one prime example is
that it's a service it's there they know
about you I was talking to a friend of
my daughter who has I think slightly
more financial Acumen he said well I've
been buying vintage clothes off one site
and selling it on another one because
this was not flattering to my generation
she said they're all these middle-aged
mums they've got cool stuff but they
don't really know what it's worth it's
amazing that's amazing well I thought
thanks honey you're not coming around
again for a while and at the same time I
completely understood what she's saying
she's like you have things in your
wardrobe and you don't know so what
young people would actually think has
got value and you probably will just
sell it for too little now would she
think of herself and a good turn this
question to you but would she think of
that as a Founder's mentality enough or
do you think there's also something that
Founders like yourself can do more of to
sort of bring down that threshold where
some people think of themselves as
entrepreneurs and others are just like I
do this thing now maybe with a bit more
thought she might grow that into
something other than you know just being
a bit cheeky to me
I so the reason that entrepreneurship is
not just my job but it's also the thing
that I I self-identified by is because I
think it's it's a way for you to build a
business but it's also the way you do
kind of anything
um when I was 13 years old more than
anything in the world it's going to
sound really silly but I want to be a DJ
um and no one would hire me to be a DJ
because I was 13 I would say I was nine
and I didn't know how to DJ
um my father who didn't have very much
money to help me start a business DJ
business uh said to me though hey if you
can't get a job being a DJ why don't you
start your own DJ company and hire
yourself and again not having much money
he made me a business card when I was
13. It was kind of made on the printer
at home you know kind of a crappy you've
still got that it said yeah but it said
Harley Finkelstein DJ and immediately my
identity changed now I actually had the
audacity I had the permission to go and
try my hand at entrepreneurship
entrepreneurship but also DJing through
entrepreneurship
um when I got to college when I was 17 I
went to McGill University
um my parents lost everything
unfortunately financially and I'd
support myself and once again I pulled
out this tool out of my pocket called
entrepreneurship and I started selling
T-shirts to the local University so the
way that I think about entrepreneurship
and or the founders mentality is that it
allows you to take this path if you were
if if you can think about it in sort of
a fast agile adaptable way okay you can
actually solve a lot of problems with
this tool called entrepreneurship and
you know Tim Cook famously has talked
about how Steve Jobs taught him that
focus is key and so I think part of that
like that founder of mentality is the
need to keep at the Forefront of
anything I mean the simplicity so not to
complicate things so you know your your
your daughter's friends saying I buy
something here and I sell it there for
more money you may say well is that
really a business is that really is that
going to be a multi-billionaire company
maybe not but maybe that particular
person's focus is just to make a couple
extra dollars so they can afford tuition
they can afford to go out on weekends
that in itself is entrepreneurship and
that's why I think it's one of the
greatest tools that humans have to solve
problems and that's something I know
that you advocate for you're a board
member of CBC in Canada but you're also
a dragon on CBC Dragon's Den next gen
Den what changes if any do you see then
if we think back you know Dragon's Den
was also such a sort of breakthrough
idea that people would really put
themselves out there and go through
quite a lot you know to get themselves
and and get what they were selling out
there and I think that certainly changed
a lot of views here in the in the UK
about what it took to be an entrepreneur
so you see it close up what changes do
you see generationally
I I think that this idea of failure
being this this sort of bad thing that
if you fail you know have this you know
it's on your forehead I failed this
thing I think that is sort of changing
um I think that uh part of it is that
the the cost of failure today in 2022 is
about as low as it's ever been
and I I mean that I mean I can back it
up with data but but I think it's just
it's obvious that you can try something
and it doesn't work it's okay the reason
that whether it's Dragon's Den
or Shark Tank or these entrepreneurship
competitions are so valuable is because
it invites more people in to participate
and not everyone you know everyone has
sort of a different version of success I
think one of the things that that that
we as sort of society you know imposes
on our entrepreneurs and our Founders as
we say look you're only successful if
you raise a bunch of money and then
eventually you get acquired or you go
public
um I have you know because we have
millions of words on the platform I get
a chance to mean Merchants whose only
reason for being an entrepreneur is that
they make the most
delicious barbecue sauce in the world or
they believe so and they simply want to
share with other people or that they
they that they got you know they work at
a retail store they work at a restaurant
they got a they got a reduction of hours
and they want to be able to start a
business or be an entrepreneur to
supplement their income so I think one
of the things that that these shows or
the this this content around
entrepreneurship has done is it invites
more people in now to be clear it also
glamorizes it and that's always been my
sort of issue with all these shows
including Dragons Den and shark tank and
all these shows is that what's like
let's not pretend like entrepreneurship
is easy it is not easy what is better
today than it was ever before is this
idea that
if you fail it's going to destroy you
that you're going to walk around with a
with a brand of yourself self-identity
that you are a failure we're failure I
think for for sort of the the younger
Generations
um and I sort of put myself almost in
that category although I think I'm the
oldest Millennial on the planet just by
by year of birth is that we sort of view
these things we view failure as the
discovery of something that did not work
and we put that Discovery in our pocket
for the next go about and and the cool
part is companies you know just going
back to Ben and Jim shark these
companies that were created like seven
years ago are now global leaders being
able to to be a competitor to Nike in
seven years it was just it wasn't
possible in previous vintages of
Entrepreneurship and business building
and that is happening every day now well
it is happening every day but we you
know we've got to be realistic that the
backdrop is slowing sales growth
obviously that's not only what happens
on Shopify it's happening everywhere and
we're seeing a lot of pivots of
businesses is that we write about you
bringing in alternative revenue streams
in in the case of Shopify that is also
lending money you know sort of fronting
money up to the people who use your
service now that's very interesting
because it obviously it keeps money
flowing through the system and offset
some of the decline that you'll be
seeing in sales but it also gets more
complicated doesn't it and I think of
interviews I've done with people like
clana and other lenders it's much more
regulatory in some ways it's easy to get
tangled up there and there's also a
certain responsibility perhaps a
different kind of responsibility to
lending money to simply saying it here's
the platform you know we obviously
there's certain things you can and can't
sell on a platform but it just seems to
be a bit more kind of fraught and I
wondered what you made of that
yeah look I think you know our ambition
is to be the entrepreneurship company I
think to be the entrepreneurship company
you you need to be there in good times
and not so good times um the reason that
we've we've now given out more than four
billion dollars of capital free cash
advances and Loans to Merchants is is
not because we had this ambition to ever
be you know A lender
um it's because we had this ambition to
help entrepreneurs and it turns out
Banks don't do a very good job of
helping entrepreneurs and small
businesses when they're just getting
started which is exactly the time when
they actually need the capital they tend
to lend after there's enough you know
that there's enough Runway that the
liability is is is much lower however
we'd simply bring a software approach to
it we say okay look we know
based on your shelter rates your traffic
your conversion rate your refunds
um your approval rates on credit cards
to your customers we think we can do a
really good job of effectively making a
decision very early on whether or not it
is a good idea to lend you money or not
we can do so much earlier than most
financial institutions most most most
banks can do that we also have you know
today something in the neighborhood of
five billion dollars of cash in our
balance sheet that we've raised over the
years post being becoming a public
company so with those two things wait a
second we can do something that that is
really valuable to small businesses and
we can do so in a way that actually does
not put Shopify at risk because we have
enough information to make really really
smart and some of them are not going to
make it aren't they and some of them are
going to have different that's right
yeah and some of them but but the key
for us though is that
the ones that do by far offset the ones
that don't and the ones that do make it
go really really large never leave
Shopify and we become more than simply
their e-commerce provider we power all
their physical stores the point of sale
we become their fulfillment and shipping
partner we become their Capital Partner
their payment partner so part of what
we're trying to do is is invite as many
people into Shopify as possible make it
as easy as possible to get started and
then knowingly not not all will succeed
but the ones do will stay with us for a
very very long time but your other point
and that I thought was so interesting is
you said it is getting more difficult
and certainly on the backdrop of post
covid the current you know the current
uh well I was just thinking about
everybody's sales growth is you know
it's not not as healthy as it was in
that sense that's right you're and
you're absolutely right and people
there's uncertainty inflation's higher
than it's been certainly I think in my
life in my entire lifetime
um one thing though that I think is
really really valuable is this idea of
where is retail happening so if you go
back to
you know 300 years ago retail always
happened at the Town Square that's where
the baker sold bread and the cobbler
sold their shoes the reason that the
Town Square was the fundamental place
where retail took place where Commerce
happened was because that's where people
were spending their time one of the
things I think that is important to
understand is we sort of you know leave
2022 and go to 2023 and into the future
is that currently the the modern day
Town Square is not online or offline or
on so it's kind of everywhere and that
each of us as consumers we actually for
the first time ever are beginning to
dictate to our favorite Brands this is
how I want to purchase I want to buy
online but pick up in store I want to go
into a great physical location and make
like you know and I want to have a
coffee in in the physical location I
want to go shopping but then you know I
don't want to carry my stuff out because
I'm going shopping elsewhere just ship
it to me in some cases I want to pay
with buy now pay later or I want to be
able to uh you know have a really easy
return policy one of the things I think
it's fun to mental if you're going to
study the future of retail and commerce
is it is going to happen absolutely
everywhere and the brands that will be
most successful will not talk about
things like Channel conflict and you
hear this from a lot of the old
traditional retailers well they'll say
you know offline is hurting online and
online's hurting offline
rather the most successful retailers and
Brands going forward will have this
almost Channel agnostic perspective that
we don't really care if you come into
our store and don't buy anything because
we know that that's in-store experience
we try on a pair of shoes that may
increase your propensity to purchase
online later on and you know you think
about Harrods for example in London I
mean I I've been to Harrods a dozen
times I probably have purchased
something one or two times when I've
been in there sometimes I'm just playing
with the puppies um sometimes I'm at
their food court but the fact that I go
in there and have this great experience
means that when I am ready to buy
something I likely will go back there
because I know it's a great experience
and that and I've seen what they have on
their shelves and I think that retail
everywhere concept is really really
important
perhaps last big thought before we close
we talked there about being more Channel
agnostic in in the Jog and say what do
you think the big business Trends are in
the coming years you've talked about us
having very multifarious retail
experience I like your idea that you
might walk into store and not buy
something but it somehow has value and I
wonder if sometimes with the physical
retailers have quite got that message
when they're sort of are you going to
buy something or get out lady you know
but I think that's very interesting I
think there is certainly so much more to
be said about these flatter platforms
than your subscription model therefore
enabling people to be sellers but have
what have I missed
I think if you listen if you go to any
retail conference industry conference
you'll hear this term Omni Channel or
multi-channel a million times I mean
again that's the wrong way to think
about it I think that you know in the
next two years or so and and I hope
you'll you'll call me out in this uh in
two years from now and you'll you'll
you'll call me back and say okay you
were you were absolutely wrong or you
were right but I really believe the next
two years talking about Omni channel
will be like talking about the color TV
you don't say the color T every TV is
fundamentally color TV I think that
um you will see most if not all brands
will simply be multi-channel by but by
default I think that's gonna be the
first thing the second thing is
I think retail will be everywhere and
will be very uh experiential
um consumers are now able to buy things
anywhere from from any from anyone from
their homes without you know and it you
don't have differentiation I think
you're joining a race of margin erosion
and so I think the retailers that will
be most successful will have this
incredible brand this incredible
experience for their consumers otherwise
it's just going to be a competition to
who can sell the cheapest thing and I
don't think that's what consumers want
the second thing I think that's really
really important is that this idea of
like social commerce for example we have
to be a little bit more patient on some
of these things right within like if you
look at Commerce happening on Tick Tock
or YouTube or across any of the meta
surfaces
he would say well I'm not really buying
very much right now on Instagram well
that's true but right now Instagram
maybe for you uses a place to discover
new brands or new types of products in
the future however you may actually
complete the purchase directly on one of
those surfaces many of which are powered
by Shopify and so for us what's really
cool is you know GMB through through
those type of social media Services
Group 5x five times uh faster uh Q2 of
this year over the previous year and
that will continue to grow which we
think is really really cool maybe the
last thing I think that's also really
important just to say is like if you
think about
um uh uh like Tick Tock um there's a
hashtag which is Tick Tock made me buy
it and Tick Tock maybe buy it has
something in the neighborhood I think
it's 26 billion mentions on Tick Tock so
this idea of of
um using some of these social platforms
and some of these new surface areas
where consumers and people are spending
their time to not only engage with a
potential consumer but simply add value
again going back to the coffee example
if you're a coffee company and coffee
brand just start talking about some of
the cool stuff about your coffee company
talk about the beans you use where it's
made why you started it tell your story
at some point some of those content
consumers will actually become buyers of
your products and I think that will
continue over time but um ultimately I
think it's going to be some of the most
exciting times of retail in the next 10
years of the last 100 years or so I
think it's gonna be immersive it's going
to be fun again and it's going to be
everywhere
before we say goodbye to you I can't
resist asking you what's the last fun
thing that you bought via Shopify
oh
um I'm using an ember mug I actually
don't have it here uh because it's uh I
left it at home today but I'm using an
ember mug e-m-b-e-r it's a coffee mug
um so my coffee doesn't actually get
cold it stays at the perfect time which
I think I have it set on 153 degrees or
something like that uh Fahrenheit
and
um I like it's such a simple thing it's
a coffee mug but the fact that from the
second I start sipping it to the end of
the uh mug of coffee it's at the perfect
temperature I think is absolutely
amazing so Ember would be one thing uh
that I that I really love um and I wear
a black T-shirt every day and you may
think well who cares black T-shirt but
there's a company called James purse um
they have retail stores all over the
world which powered by Shopify physical
retail stores and online and James the
the brand but also the person he thinks
more about black t-shirts and t-shirts
in general than anybody else I've ever
met and so I loved the James purse
Brandon t-shirts I think they're an
amazing job but it's because like they
do one thing really really well and it's
mostly t-shirts and they're exceptional
and as you're Canadian you'll get I
think you're gonna like my latest
purchase which I put so much work into
finding and getting to the UK and it's
the Frasier fur Christmas candle which
is just a wonderful scented candle and
for about two years because of all the
difficulties of shipping Etc the
pandemic it was almost impossible to get
in the UK and I have this stash of them
like the sort of goleming collection the
Golem collection of the most delicious
Canadian scented candle you can ever
sniff
well thank you so much Harley
Finkelstein president of Shopify I think
it's been a fascinating conversation for
me and I hope it was for you too
it was thank you Anne thank you for
taking an interest in in this topic uh
this is all I think about all the time
and I'm very very grateful for this
conversation it was a lot of fun I think
we got that I'm Anne Michael well you've
been listening to Intelligence Squared